freedom lies in the shadows but would I
desire lies in the lights
it's been ten years since the last thief
game cause stealth fans have just been
itching for something to steal
yet the announcement of idols Montreal's
reboot of the iconic stealth series was
met with outrage from its most hardcore
followers
what are these quick time events doing
in a thief's game why do I own
experience points for getting a headshot
more importantly why is everything
exploding I just Montreal responded to
the backlash by cutting those QuickTime
events as well as the entire experience
point system it's a move that the
developer was already leaning towards
internally we realized that it was
wreaking a Liberty economy system it was
not encouraging that much distilling
aspect whoa hey wait a minute not
encouraging the stealing aspect for a
game called thief that meant something
was terribly wrong but after playing the
first five hours with these more modern
mechanics removed I can say that I'd
lost Montreal made the right decision
thief is a much better game now because
it makes players focus entirely on
stealing and there were only a couple of
explosions now the experience points are
gone everything in the game costs money
they from buy more hours for your bow
upgrade your defenses or make a
blackjack do a bit more damage in combat
you're gonna need to spend some coin if
you don't visit a vendor in the city's
hub and say stock up on rope arrows
you're not going to be able to take
advantage of every opportunity that
level affords you and how do you make
sure you'll be able to afford it just
steal everything that isn't nailed down
and if the nails are shiny take them to
if you want to steal a lot is because
you're going to get money and then
you're going to be able to buy new items
in three about that when I was talking
about the economy system that encouraged
you to steal it's all the loop I'm gonna
steal that you go in there and you want
to buy this is this I'm going to steal
more to be able to buy capitalism at its
finest being an entrepreneur in the
Victorian era industrial sprawl of the
city isn't easy but that's how
classically fans liked it to ease those
less skilled at pilfering pockets into
the stealth genre Idols Montreal has at
a division mode called focus that allows
garrote to see key points of interest
highlighted in blue
that includes guards switches traps loot
and anything that can be interacted with
really focus has yet another system to
spend your money on as you're able to
buy upgrades to eventually see footsteps
through walls slow down time and deal
more damage in combat it's an attempt to
let players experience the power fantasy
of being a master thief without them
having to actually master thief we want
to make sure that the people in what
don't wanna like challenge them too much
and can jump in a game of disturbia and
really like you said enjoyed it the
fantasy focus allows players to overcome
situations that would have spelled
certain death in the earlier thief games
and that's the major thing that our DOS
Montreal is trying to address with this
reboot they don't want the act of
getting spotted to feel like it's game
over focus makes thief a little more
forgiving but also a little less
immersive the city is rendered with such
attention to detail that playing with
this vision mode which highlights
everything important means you don't
need to pay as much attention to the
world as a whole I played for a few
hours with focus disabled as well as
with the heads up display turned off and
the game was so much more atmospheric
because of it something that might break
your emotion a little bit is the fact
that this new thief has a lot more
cutscenes Garrett you have talent lad
the previous thief trilogy played
cutscenes at the start of each mission
but beyond those it never interrupted
gameplay this helped players feel
completely immersed in the world and in
their role as Garrett in my time playing
the reboot it felt like every few
minutes I was being interrupted and my
control was being taken away by
third-person cutscenes the main story is
really important in our game so often
again play why don't you do playing
first-person it's really about the
gameplay itself he has the world gonna
tell you a lot about the story and
things but a cutscene are there ready to
outline the story and I think instead of
breaking your experience they will had
to it to make sure you want to pursue it
and we're also proud of the character
and I think we wanted to show him a
little bit we've put a lot of effort on
that and we wanted to show it but not to
the detriment of the gameplay itself
that's why also we put a lot of time and
energy in the hand
feedback the way to interact with the
world you know you really feel it's not
just generic hands it's the carats hand
and that element was really important
for us to feel that you're part of the
world if you touch the walls if you take
the object instead of just bricks and it
go in your inventory you can look at it
if it's a special loo you know all those
other men to become garret in fact yes
idols Montreal wants everyone to become
garret but only one of them will become
the ultimate master thief for the first
time in the series thief will include
leaderboards that track how well you
play in the campaign as well as your
performance in the game's new challenge
maps are DOS Montreal isn't revealing
much about these right now but they do
hint it they're very similar to the maps
featured in the recent Batman games so
expect bite-sized chunks of stealth
gameplay that allows players to compete
with one another it's there to challenge
all your thievery steal skills and
abilities so people will kind of compare
themselves and I hope it will become
something really interesting even though
in the studio people are really I did
that mission in two minutes instead yeah
but did you still though so people like
it's it's about your gameplay and I
think the competitive aspect of the game
will bring a good challenge to the that
challenge no never no one will be
invited to a ball leaderboards challenge
Maps a completely customizable level of
difficulty with these thief is looking
to be the stealth game for everyone but
there's one thing I think all players
can agree on and Nikolas says it best
yeah it's become addictive to steal
I never paid the price for anything
until now